so last night
unfortunately and i get that the
reporter was doing her job but
unfortunately he was asked to respond to
the la county sheriff
uh calling out lebron james and asking
him to double the reward for any
information in connection with the
shooting of a couple of uh los angeles
police officers and here was lebron's
response
but you know when you see the videos
that's going on and you can see that you
know all over not only
you know my hometown but you know all
over america you continue to see uh the
acts of violence towards my kind i can't
do nothing but to speak about it and and
see uh you know the the common
denominator um but not one time have i
ever said
uh you know let's act violent towards
cops um i just said that you know what's
going on in our community um is not okay
and and we fear for that and we fear for
our lives um it's something that we we
go on every single day um as a black man
and a black woman and a black kid a
black girl um we fear uh we fear that
moment uh where we're pulled over or or
you know
you know i just seen something i believe
yesterday or the day before of a guy in
wisconsin
was renting a house
and um the next door neighbor called the
police on them and the police came in
the house
without a warrant without anything
and arrested a guy a black man
because he was sitting out on a porch
um and if you can't tell me that's not
racial profiling then i don't know what
the hell uh what the hell we're looking
at um but i do not condone violence
towards anyone police uh black people
white people
anyone of color anyone not of color um
you know because that's not gonna ever
uh make this uh world or america um you
know what we want it to be so
and i have zero comment
um on the sheriff
he handled that beautifully as always he
did but he shouldn't have had to do that
he shouldn't have to answer that
question he shouldn't have to dignify
the question or the sheriff with any
kind of response he shouldn't have to
explain he doesn't condone violence
because we know exactly what the fox
news is of the world and
and and his attackers are trying to do
trying to deflect from the real issue
and somehow place
criminal activity blamed for violence
against police at the feet of people
like lebron james who are talking about
statesman which is nonsense against
black that's nonsense exactly states and
and listen i'm the reason i'm bringing
it up is because i'm bringing it up in
the case of brianna taylor because it's
not this it's not that complicated to to
hear what he's saying
that the fact that people still don't
get that that's so basic shout out to
michael che a stand-up comedian he had a
bit recently he was talking about just
how how bare and how basic black lives
matter is
they matter
that's all they matter i mean they drew
laughter but it was you have to keep
from crying right it's just not saying
that they just matter how minimal of an
ask is it for black lives to matter and
even because
that becomes controversial for some
people and that's controversial
yeah somebody somebody said it uh i
think somebody said it best racism is so
american
until fighting against racism
is characterized as anti-american
you know black lives matter isn't
anti-white
stop killing us is not anti-police
and yet you see the situation like what
happened with you know no charges in
connection with brianna taylor's uh
murder
being filed today
and people can still step back and
they're going to look at the response
and the uprising
and you know and the peaceful protests
and try to vilify
peaceful protesters when we're out of
answers at this point we're out of
answers and even when we do we speak up
about it you got people on the right
deciding to twist the conversation
to benefit their agenda so
ron for handling that
but i would say this uh yeah right and i
agree i think he handled it well but i
think there are a lot of people
uh who are so tied to their political
positions they're not really having
conversations with you they are going
down a list of talking points so they
got their talking points and no matter
what you say they go back you know go
back to that home base of okay i gotta
go i gotta cycle through my talking
points and i say that i'm gonna say this
i'm gonna say this
i would suggest and lebron james handled
it beautifully i would suggest not even
getting uh caught up in that because
you're not really having a conversation
with somebody all they're looking for is
some area some space where they can take
what you're saying take a phrase
uh take a couple of phrases and twist it
around
and as i said earlier this has been
going on for a long time mike you know
you mentioned michael che
uh richard pryor one of his bits like
years ago
yes he's talking about uh you know
the difference when black people get
pulled over by the police
you know i am reaching into the job
compartment you know i have nothing at
fox before
yeah absolutely right so i mean this has
been going on for a while
it's not it's not a lack of
understanding it's not a lack of
comprehension it is absolutely
ignorance it is resistance and so
the the question is how do you deal with
that and there and there's no there's no
right answer for lebron james he he
chose not to comment on on the sheriff's
comment
some people will come back and say okay
well you're going to say this i'm going
to we'll go back and forth and get into
a war of words there's no yeah right no
that
that willful ignorance is is the point
here because
you know you shouted him out earlier we
talked about the last couple of days
nobody has been more eloquent on the
subject of systemic racism in this
country this country's one of this
country's original sin the first was a
genocide of native americans the second
of course the institution of slavery
nobody was more elegant eloquent than
frederick douglass specifically what to
the slave is the fourth of july
nobody has been has written about the
struggles of the white moderate
and and and and the pushback against
protests
better than martin luther king did
in a letter from a birmingham jail which
you have so appropriately called
something deserving of this being the
67th book of the bible so this guy this
is there is nothing new to this but what
is but what can't what is kind of new
what is new
once upon a time people like lebron i
said this last night to somebody
once upon a time people like lebron were
rare
in sports
it was a rare athlete who would dare
speak out on social justice and racial
justice that was that was taboo in
sports every night and they will come
along but for the most part hey i'm just
here to play ball
that's right yeah um
now
it's not just lebron you're superstars
you're faces of the league you're
established players it's your jaylen
browns and everybody in between
you know george hill
yeah there you go you know it's like so
many people
yes so many people have found their
voices or at least have
realized it's time for me to use my
voice and look generally speaking but
specific to athletes it's not on black
people to fix a problem we didn't solve
and athletes are far too often pressured
with carrying a burden
of of of of leading a movement you know
against a system that again it is
designed to work this way but i don't
mean to digress my point is though what
i love about lebron even though he
should not have had to say that last
night even though
it's beneath him and he shouldn't have
dignified with a response
there are this having a generational
impact
because there are children much like our
parents or even uh some of us
grew up watching ali take his stance and
we were shaped by that now in our
mindset and our approach and our
paradigm was shaped by the way ali was
an athlete activist a citizen first
there are children right now
who are watching lebron and chris paul
and jaylen brown and watching how
civic-minded their role models are how
civic-minded and how active and how
politically engaged
their favorite players are and they're
going to be inspired by that they're
going to be much more involved in the
process than we were in a generation
before because of the example so when
lebron is doing that last night there's
some kids out there watching how to
handle things with class dignity and
most important intelligence and here's a
question you know and i'll i'll be brief
on this one
um the question is can you have the can
you can you find the type of job it used
to be hey find a job that you love and
if you can happen to make some money at
it even better the the number one thing
is you're finding a job that you love
i'm going to add to it find a job that
you love and you can bring your whole
self to it so what you're saying
is like these athletes who used to
compartmentalize some of them did it
because they wanted to some of them did
it because they felt like they had to
but now you don't have to
just bring bring everything that you are
to the job and and some people will love
you for it and some people will will be
turned off but that's going to be the
case
anyway
that's going to happen anyway
you